choisir un prénom tout un art un motif
de dispute aussi parfois mais toujours
bien sûr un moment important alors pour
aider les futurs parents un guide sort
chaque année à la version 2024 sera
disponible demain sachez que chez les
filles le prénom Alba casse la baraque
et devrait détrôner le trio Louise Jade
et Ambre côté garçon le tiercé reste
inchangé Gabriel Léo Raphaël arrive en
tête devant Noah et Maëlle la mode des
prénoms anciens est également toujours
de mise Léon fait ainsi son entrée dans
le Top 20 chez les garçons et Louise
rose et Emma il reste en bonne plage
chez les filles et les autrices du guide
des prénoms dont on va parler de notes
également chez les fillettes la montée
des prénoms médiévaux comme Aliénor
Clotilde ou Margot et chez les garçons
les sonorités régionales s'imposent avec
des prénoms bretons corsubas comme Malo
comme Agustin et Louane ou Andrea
non c'est pas pour moi ça
vas-y
et les prénoms issus de différentes
mythologies devraient également
connaître leur heure de gloire en 2024
comme Élysée ou Rodin ce sont les
prénoms masculins
en revanche des prénoms en forte
croissance ces dernières années comme
Achille Zain Célestine et Diana
devraient être moins attribué en 2024 tu
penses que je pourrais être bon après
tu sais que ça me fait quand même
plaisir
je peux avoir un bisou moi
tout de suite parce que le problème
c'est pas les enfants c'est des parents
des parents de ses enfants et bien sûr
vous n'avez pas d'enfants vous bah non
et alors connard excusez-moi
en plus le mépris vous avez épiler les
papas bobos les modernes ont plutôt
et qui
montre bien qu'ils sont père et qui
s'occupe de leurs enfants mais c'est les
pires je voulais commencer par vous
montrer et bien cette image c'est
l'image d'un d'un itinéraire le vol
Delta qui était censé faire un trajet
Atlanta Barcelone sauf que vous pouvez
le voir sur cette image il a fait
demi-tour au bout de deux heures de vol
alors pourquoi avoir décidé de
rebrousser le chemin c'est pas à cause
d'une erreur technique et une
explication beaucoup plus originale
disons on va écouter l'enregistrement
que le pilote a fait au contrôleur
aérien j'adore c'est chouette
mon rôle de maman depuis 11 ans fait que
quand je vois du coton forcément pour
moi le coton c'est pour nettoyer les
fesses des enfants
je me dis que voilà ce sera un bouquet
recyclable il a expliqué qu'il devait se
poser en urgence on écoute c'est une
question de risque sanitaire nous avons
un passager qui a la diarrhée il y en a
partout dans l'avion donc ils veulent
que nous revenions Atlanta
bon appétit bonjour
vous avez bien entendu
faire demi-tour parce qu'un passager
avait la diarrhée alors sur X
anciennement
le paresseux descend des arbres
uniquement pour faire crac-crac ou pour
faire popo
je dirais popo et c'est une bonne
réponse
il y a pas mal d'internautes qui se
présente comme des passagers de cet
avion qui expliquent que c'était
vraiment chaotique qui en avait partout
voilà j'ai pas donné trop de détails
j'ai peur
que l'odeur était très difficile à
supporter
est-ce qu'il manque de fois les amis
pour tomber sur un hic un indice
un hic François
[Musique]
pardon et finalement c'était bien le
pôle aurait dû durer 8 heures il a fait
demi-tour au bout de 2h parce que
vraiment apparemment c'était
insoutenable donc
après on sait pas au bout de combien de
temps il est à diarrhée
donc en tout cas ils sont revenus à
Atlanta l'avion a été nettoyé de fond en
comble ils ont pu le reprendre ils sont
arrivés à Barcelone avec 8 heures de
retard comment ne pas parler de ça les
Belges comment ne pas parler de cette
affaire qui fait la Une chez vous la Une
du journal de la chaîne publique RTBF
hier
à la Une les images du ministre de la
Justice lors de sa soirée d'anniversaire
[Musique]
c'est ça lui plusieurs fois elle m'a dit
de rentrer chez moi et de cette quartier
c'est pas pour personne que moi
il a fait pipi c'est avant
j'ai mis la pépite dans un boite les
images du ministre de la Justice lors de
sa soirée d'anniversaire c'est lui-même
qu'il les fournit il veut clore la
déplaisante affaire dite du pipi gate
ça c'est le pépé de Monsieur mais
maintenant c'est ça fait longtemps donc
vous avez gardé ce pipi alors il dit que
moi je ne parle il m'a dit tu n'es pas
profond c'est quand c'est comme ça que
c'était con tu m'avais vu c'est comme ça
qui m'a répondu j'ai dit j'ai le pipi
dans la boîte la jauge pour dire que
d'aller à faire analyse pour savoir si
c'est ton pipi ou non vous regardez
premier sur l'info et elle a une
aujourd'hui du nouveau dans l'affaire du
pipi gate la sucette de Matin Première
les suites toujours de ce que certains
appellent le pipi gate l'affaire
baptiser pipi gate 10
il fait grand bruit le tollé
le Taure
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à 21h avec Aurélie pierre Mohamed
Patrick et Christian du Plessis ça sent
bon j'ai faim et envie de faire pipi
cette affaire qui oblige la presse à
raconter une histoire avec des mots que
normalement on utilise jamais à la télé
la serre d'une soirée d'anniversaire
trop arrosée et d'alcool et d'urine
et merci de nous avoir amené les rectors
de jeux de
[Musique]
constructions de jouets et bien vous
allez nous raconter tout ça dans
quelques instants Vincent vaincu kenborn
veut nous montrer des images de
vidéosurveillance là vous voyez je
m'incline à l'arrière
cette séquence où le ministre de la
Justice se débrief lui-même bourré on
dirait un épisode de Black Mirror